it'll be his 17th start he has really
become a horse in fact huey if you go
back to mid
2018 he's thrown the most innings in the
national league what an oda adam frazier
3 30 and he pulls that what a catch by
fuentes
he thought he was going to gallop to
second for another double of which he's
accumulated a ton of this year
fuentes at first this is uh flat out
robbery yeah and right after that herman
took his hat off
and tipped it to joshua said thanks bud
and this is a weak ground ball to second
and it's a great start little help from
josh fuentes chase de young five starts
0-2 494 the era bidding for his first
win as a pirate big league start number
16 for de young
it's a ground ball to start
there's a fly ball but weekly hit to
short right
frazier watson has it
one two three go the rockies a scoreless
first inning de young now facing the
four five and six hitters in the rockies
lineup short hop liner that gets under
the glove of the second baseman adam
frazier out in short right field and
ryan mcmahon becomes the rockies first
base runner but a one out base runner
and garrett hampson drives it towards
right center field gamble on the run
it's over his head it short hops the
wall
mcmahon getting the go ahead he scores
all the way from first
rbi doubled by garrett hampson the
rockies take advantage of the air
and lead it one to nothing here's joshua
fuentes
and he's got himself a basic to ride
hanson around third flight at home tune
it up they colorado
it was almost like he was trying to hit
it that way because of where adam
frazier was
positioned up the middle
slider up and away drives it right to
where fraser
had been positioned earlier
kai tom the left fielder left hand
batter to face airman marquez in the
first pitch is hit the other way towards
left tapia coming up and has to stop in
his tracks and lean back a little bit to
snag that line drive almost over ran it
next pitch is grounded back to marcus on
a couple of hops he has it throws to
first and it's another one two three
inning for airmon marquez who is sharp
early on charlie blackman will get his
second look tonight at chase de young
and
that will help the career average at
coolsfield
and this gets away charlie the second he
may be able to stretch this we'll see
he's headed towards third and he'll get
there easily
a great opportunity here for mack
here he comes he is out blackman running
on contact thrown out at the plate
and that's a big out that's a big play
right there um
rocky's being aggressive going on
contact the bare hand the flip to
stallings close play we'll see the tag
was up high does that front foot hit
doesn't look like it two to nothing the
rockies with the lead inning number five
here at coors field swung on and missed
second strikeout for herman
he's got working tonight he's got it
working off late
set up down and away that was pitch was
in the strike zone for just a moment
and then
stalling says i think i can get it no
you can't
newman grounded to third first time up
and he'll bounce it to short backhanded
by story to second for one hanson at
first double play
five innings of pitching herman marquez
is not allowed to hit elias diaz in the
home half of the fifth against chase de
young
diaz leans on this one deep left center
field he's done it again
back-to-back ball games with a big fly
and it feels a little extra special
against the team he came up with
he really stayed back on this off-speed
pitch
he's worked so hard and
it's really good to see him having
success this one went
451 feet yeah that was a curveball and
he got everything behind that
[Applause]
down the line that's a fair ball hayes
was well off the line and her mom
is going to cruise into second with the
double
and that is his second double of the
year the former silver slumber award
winner in the national league charlie
blackmon is single in three tries
i don't know
he kind of threw the change up there he
kind of just
guided it to first charlie beat it
according to dad burzel and the rockies
get a run out of it and trevor story
will try and keep the inning going
this ball is scorched to left center
field and it is
going to take one hop off the wall
charlie long squatting it he gets a
green light he'll score five nothing on
the double by story rbi double trevor
story
a three run fifth inning and a five
nothing rockies lead
sixth inning rockies have a five to
nothing lead now and kai tom the number
eight hitter and
swung on and missed
and tom is gone third strikeout for
hermione sweating
he went out even farther and got
gonzales to chase it back-to-back
strikeouts here in the sixth inning
here's the 1-1
this is lifted pretty well to
right-center field but playable out
there for dazzle and it's a one two
three sixth inning for vermont that out
here in the sixth keeps the no hitter
going cody potts just five innings of
work see how he does here against the
rockies two outs marcus struck out in
the third inning this one is going to be
another double as he rips it to
left center field it's going to go all
the way to the wall rbi double for
airmon marquez
six nothing rockies
[Applause]
down the line a vintage
base hit
and double
for rydel tapia
make it seven nothing load up the tacos
rocky's having a night airman marquez
has been fantastic working the first six
innings
on 60 pitches
and uh ground ball takes a bad hops dory
recovers and gets his man age runs well
i don't like three bad hops in it
swung on and missed
two outs in the seventh
[Applause]
a special evening at coors field for
hermann marcus it'll be charlie blackman
leading off for the rockies
that's pulled to the corner
it's a fair ball right on the line
charlie takes a look over his shoulder
and says you know what i'm headed to
third
stand up triple for chuck nasty
second of the year
story comes up
and that's a base hit charlie can come
on down make it eight nothing colorado
second rbi the night for story he's got
36 on the season
eighth inning for hermann he'll see
stallings evans and newman five six and
seven
blind drop
trevor story oh man remember that one
trevor story
timing his lead
grabs the stallings liner five outs to
go
in the air
right center
now we go the one two ground balls
slowly hit the second hamson charges
throws to first and got him
eight
no hit innings for airmon marcus
ninth inning rockies lead it eight to
nothing here mon marquez is not allowed
to hit
[Applause]
what an effort
stand up and cheer right now fans thank
you
simply remarkable
and now a double play ball perhaps
there's one
there's two
and frazier will roll it to second
hampson to first
it's a one hit
gem
from airmon marquez the rockies beat the
pittsburgh pirates
eight to nothing